It's not going to be same here without you, Bridgewater
We'll be watching when Forbath pulls a Walsh
in the Wild Card
See you on the field soon, Teddy
Andrew, nobody has any idea what's wrong with you
or if you'll even play again
That's ok
Dear fellas
I can't believe how fast things move on the outside
Hey, watch it old-timer!
Seems like the world went and got itself
in one big hurry-up offense
I saw a touchdown celebration once when I was a kid
But now, they're everywhere
I was 22 then
I'm 24 now
I remember when Los Angeles was just a
place teams threatened to move to
Now, they got a team and a half
And nobody seems to care
Somedays I think I should just take a cheap shot
from Fletcher Cox, so they'll send me home to the IR
But just when I thought the league had passed me by
I realized
Some things never change